you know um I guess what I would say is
that this whole process has been a
search for allies you know and it's just
you're looking for people who who
understand this and and really deeply
believe in it and want to help make it
happen and there are plenty of people
out there who who have said no along the
way or for whatever reason don't you
know haven't gravitated to this as the
fundamental you know force that that I
think it has the potential to be but but
for everyone who who hasn't been
compelled there there's at least one
person who has and really all you need
to you know grow a social enterprises is
enough allies you know so i guess i
think persistence in finding supporters
and and in just expanding constantly the
the set of true believers out there is
is a huge piece of what it takes to
really ultimately make social enterprise
work
I would say yes this has been and we've
been at this for 18 years now and it has
been just an incessant learning curve on
every front in terms of you know
actually even just how do we manage
something on a significant scale how do
we ensure its financial sustainability
how do we navigate a very complex
education policy environment and most
centrally really you know how do we do
this well like how do we recruit the
select people straight out of college to
teach in the most challenging teaching
situations in the country and not just
survive but really excel with their kids
so that they do in fact help put kids
growing up today on the level playing
field with kids in other communities and
and as a result learn the right lessons
rather than becoming more disillusioned
actually become more committed to the
possibility of change it's incredibly
complex set of things to figure out all
the same time how to how to do well and
i would say that we're still on the
learning curve on every piece of that
we're probably one of the greatest
strengths of Teach for America has been
that we sort of we knew at the front end
that we didn't have the answers and we
set out to find them and have been just
so open and responsive and really
searching for help on every level of
this and continue to be so our program
has evolved just completely dramatically
you know based on feedback from the core
members themselves our own research into
what is working and what isn't working
feedback from experienced teachers and
educators and such and and the same is
true at every on every dimension of what
we do I mean I think you know we try
hard to be successful but inevitably
just learn many lessons along the way
and and so I think that embracing you
know the process of constant learning
and continuous improvement is honestly
probably part of the core of our success